[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing lucius malfoy the death
eaters
and whether or not lucius was able to
cast a patronus charm
we know lucius malfoy as the father of
draco malfoy and son of abraxis malfoy
he was a proud pure blood wizard that
hailed from the malfoy family
and had every intention of living up to
his pure blood status
to the malfoys and lucius to a
significant degree
reputation was everything and it was
this obsession with
image keeping up appearances and
preserving the population of
pure blood witches and wizards that
drove lucius to join
the death eaters the four runners to
what would eventually become the death
eaters were once described by dumbledore
as
a mixture of the weak seeking protection
the ambitious seeking glory
and the thuggish seeking a leader who
could show the more refined cruelty
the death eaters became known as a group
of pureblood radical supremacists
that served lord voldemort in the name
of preserving blood purity
they made their perspective very clear
they didn't want muggle-born wizards or
half-bloods they wanted to keep the
bloodlines pure
this supremacist viewpoint requires a
very particular type of person
a bad person so this opens up the
question of whether or not any of them
are able to conjure
a patronus charm a very pure piece of
magic
before we jump into this further let me
first clear up what exactly a patronus
is
in essence patronus is the result of a
witch or wizard casting the patronus
charm
there are two types of patronus charms
corporeal and incorporeal
the more basic form of the spell is the
incorporeal which assumes no animal form
and simply resembles a burst of white
vapour or smoke
the more advanced form of the spell is
the conjuring of a corporeal patronus
the ability to successfully cast a
corporeal patronus
is considered an impressive feat in the
wizarding world the corporeal patronus
assumes the form of the witch or wizards
spirit animal and varies extensively
from which to which
or wizard to wizard and while casting
spells that create your very own spirit
animal is probably fun
there is a purpose and that purpose is
to ward off dementors or
leather folds dark creatures that feed
on human happiness
and incite a feeling of despair and
anyone that gets close to them
the patronus charm is the only known way
of dealing with the dementor
and so it's a gravely important thing
for a witch or wizard to know
the patronus represents everything that
dementor doesn't
hope happiness survival and purity as
the patronus itself does not feel
despair or
hopelessness as a human might the
dementors can't hurt it and are repelled
by its presence
it should be mentioned however that
because death eaters are evil themselves
they actually share a lot of traits that
dementors have this makes them less
likely targets for a dementor's attack
but it doesn't mean that they're safe
from them and this is why they are still
used to keep death eaters
and other dark wizards inside of azkaban
but can death eaters cast a patronus
charm
in the event that they are attacked by
dementor can lucius malfoy
sniveling death eater conjure one to
cast a patronus you need to hone your
positive emotions
hope happiness and desire and in my
opinion
i don't think that lucius malfoy had the
capacity to effectively hone these
emotions
sure him and his family defected from
the death eaters eventually
but it was for entirely selfish reasons
they wanted to stay alive and they
wanted to avoid imprisonment
lucius sort of loves his family but in a
lot of ways they're just pawns in his
life
ways that he can sustain the pure blood
malfoy bloodline
he needs a son to keep the malfoy name
alive and he needs a wife to have a son
did he love them sure somewhat but was
it love in its purest form
i don't think so lucius is actually
quite an evil man
and while he did show some form of
regret for what he did as a death eater
in part due to what it did to his family
his motivations were still mainly
related to sustaining his image
and while lucius was quite evil he was
equally less brave
and was unable to speak up when the dark
lord placed his own son
in danger he should have defected right
then and there
but he was too much of a coward and it's
lucius cowardice that is his downfall
and probably the reason that he would
never be able to effectively conjure a
patronus
for most of his life lucius allied
himself with the worst people imaginable
he engineered mass child murder in the
second and fifth books
though they both failed tortured muggles
and took joy and humiliation
torture and death of people he hated at
one point in the order of the phoenix
it's mentioned that lucius was jeering
at the sight of a fourteen-year-old
harry
being tortured he fundamentally lacks
the capacity
to hone the emotions necessary to
conjure a patronus
his heart is not pure enough
additionally it has been revealed by jk
rowling that snape is in fact the only
death eater able to produce a patronus
and no dark wizard not even lord
voldemort has been able to successfully
produce one
okay so lucius can't cast a patronus but
if he could what would it be i have a
theory
one creature that lucius has always
shown an affinity for in canon
were peacocks this is interesting
because peacocks are known for
well peacocking and showing off does
this remind you of someone
when snape and you actually meet at the
malfoy manor for death eater meeting
a peacock on the malfoy manic grounds
alarmed yaxley
it rustled the bushes as it strutted
alarming yaxley
who drew his wand but put it away once
he saw the noise's source
he always did well for himself lucius
peacocks
he remarked while the peacock on the
grounds was white many made the
assumption that the peacock itself was a
corporeal patronus
however it was later revealed by rowling
that the peacock was in fact
albino regardless of this fact i think
that if
lucius were able to cast a patronus the
corporeal form would match the bird
that walked the malfoy manor grounds and
that's it for this video
if you enjoyed the content please like
the video and subscribe to the channel
until next time you're a wizard harry